allein auf dem Maß gestrandet muss der
Botaniker Mark Watney monatelang in
einer lebensfeindlichen Welt überleben
bis seine Crew ihn mit einem krassen
stand rettet das ist die mega spannende
Story von der masiana und natürlich habe
ich mich gefragt könnte der masiana
wirklich so passieren würde ein Mark
Watney wirklich allein auf dem Mars
überleben und könnte so eine wahnwitzige
Rettungsaktion wirklich funktionieren
das beantworten wir heute mit zwei
Experten von denen eine wirklich schon
mal eine jährige maßmission gemacht hat
und ich kann schon mal so viel verraten
vieles im Film stimmt aber es gibt
mindestens einen Punkt der die ganze
Geschichte kollabieren
lässt der masianaer von Ridley Scott
soll besonders realistisch sein und die
Buchvorlage ist natürlich noch viel
besser tatsächlich soll der Autor Andy
sich tief in die wissenschaftlichen
Themen reingefuchst haben aber stimmt
das wirklich um das zu überprüfen haben
wir zwei Experten geladen Volker Schmidt
ist Luft und Raumfahrt systemingenieur
und war viele Jahre lang zuständig für
die ISS und Astronautik beim deutschen
Zentrum für Luft und Raumfahrt dabei hat
er tagtäglich mit Astronauten wie
alexander Gerst und Matthias Maurer
gearbeitet und dr Christiana heinike ist
Forscherin für angewandte
Raumfahrttechnologie und beschäftigt
sich damit wie man
maßstationen für Menschen bauen kann und
sie hat sogar schon ein Jahr lang auf
dem Mars gelebt natürlich nicht auf dem
echten sondern in einer simulierten
Station auf Hawaii dort lebt sie mit
einer realistisch zusammengesetzten Crew
auf engem Raum zusammen essen Wasser
Sauerstoff alles war rationiert mit der
Außenwelt konnte sie nur mit 20 Minuten
Verzögerung kommunizieren und rausgehen
ging nur in einer sorgfältig geplanten
Außenmission im Raumanzug das heißt ich
war auf dem simulierten Maß tatsächlich
als der Film rauskam und die die
Produktionsfirma hat uns dann
tatsächlich den Film zur Verfügung
gestellt dass wir ihn auf dem Maß den
aner gucken konnten also ich würde sagen
wir haben die perfekten Experten um über
maßmissionen zu sprechen und jetzt
klären wir Fragen wie wo kommt der
Sauerstoff für so eine Mission her wie
kommuniziere ich mit den Menschen auf
der Erde und wie würde die Station auf
dem Mars in echt
aussehen die Station hat Vorräte die
schon vor den Astronauten mit einigen
versorgungsflügen angeliefert wurden das
ist realistisch ob die Astronauten die
Station gebaut haben oder die Station
sich robotisch selbst errichtet hat das
wissen wir nicht zumindest nicht im Film
man arbeitet allerdings in der Realität
definitiv an vollautomatischen Lösungen
es wäre für die Astronauten ja einfacher
und auch sicherer wenn bei ihrer Ankunft
schon eine funktionsfähige Station auf
sie warten würde ein Hauptproblem auf
dem Mars ist Wasser es gibt zwar Wasser
auf dem Mars aber die Station hat keine
externe Wasserquelle Watney ist also
komplett auf die Wasseraufbereitung
angewiesen dazu gibt es tatsächlich
heute schon brauchbare Technologien die
z.B auf der ISS eingesetzt werden etwa
80 bis 90% des Urins wird wieder
verwendet und wenn jemand Sport treibt
und schwitzt dann diese Luftfeuchtigkeit
geht auch ins System es wird auch
rausgezogen um den Geschmack muss man
sich da übrigens keine Sorgen machen das
wird natürlich alles gefiltert aber der
Kreislauf ist noch nicht perfekt und die
ISS braucht auch heute noch zusätzliche
Wasserlieferungen auch die autonome
Sauerstoffversorgung im Film ist
realistisch das hat der Prototyp Moxi
dieses Jahr erst bewiesen der wurde mit
dem aktuellen Mass Rover perseverance
zum mß geschickt und getestet zunächst
verdichtet er die dünne maßluft die aus
rund 95% Kohlendioxid besteht dann macht
er mittels Elektrolyse aus zwei
Molekülen CO2 zwei Moleküle
Kohlenmonoxid und ein o2 bei Abschluss
des Tests im September 2023 konnte die
NASA verkünden es hat besser
funktioniert als er hofft aber ein ganz
wichtiger Aspekt fehlt beim Masi und das
ist der Strahlenschutz wenn ich mir das
das Habitat angucke wie es im Film
dargestellt ist da ist kein
Strahlenschutz es gibt ja weltweit eine
ganze Reihe von analogkavitaten die hat
für Simulationen für maßsimulationen
gebaut worden sind und keins davon hat
ein Strahlenschutz oder wenigstens ein
Konzept für den Strahlenschutz für die
humans on mass Initiative an der
Christiane mitarbeitet ist
Strahlenschutz aber ein großes Thema
schließlich ist die Belastung auf dem
Maß 40 bis 50 Mal so hoch wie hier auf
der Erde der beste strah Schutz wäre die
Station in Wasser einzuhüllen
tonnenweise Wasser aber das ist
natürlich schwierig auf dem Maß die
zweitbeste Lösung ist deshalb das
Habitat in regulit zu verpacken das ist
der feine Staub der dem Maß seine Farbe
verleiht auch davon bräuchte es Meter
dicke Wände aber wir sehen davon nichts
im Film es besteht also ein massives
Krebsrisiko für mad Damon und das würde
in der Realität wohl niemand eingehen
wollen aber vermutlich wollte man
einfach die schöne Station auch von
außen zeigen können sei den Filmemachern
also Verziehen der regulit bringt uns
aber auch gleich zu dem Teil des Films
der vielen am besten im Gedächtnis
geblieben ist es geht um Kartoffeln
Knallgas und
Kot kurz nachdem Mark Watney wegen eines
Sandsturms allein auf dem marß
gestrandet ist stellt er fest bis die
nächste Marsmission ankommt wird er
verhungern aber der Botaniker findet
Kartoffeln unter den Rationen also baut
er einen Acker mit regulit erzeugt
zusätz Wasser und benutzt den
gefriergrockneten Code der Crew als
Dünger das Wasser stellt er her indem er
den Treibstoff Hydrazin zu Wasserstoff
und Stickstoff spaltet und dann den
Wasserstoff mit Sauerstoff in einer
Knallgasreaktion zu Wasser reagieren
lässt dabei bringt er sich fast um aber
prinzipiell könnte das alles schon sehr
gut klappen eine richtig dumme Idee ist
aber der regulitacker würde Mars regulit
nicht ins Innere des Habitats holen also
zum einen
ja ich meine es ist es ist Staub klar
den kann ich Einatmen zum anderen der
der
regulit ich glaub das hat man
rausgefunden nachdem das Buch schon
geschrieben wurde oder geschrieben war
und der regulit enthält an an vielen
Stellen auf dem Maß perchlorate und
perchlorate sind für Menschen giftig und
nicht nur für Menschen sondern auch für
Pflanzen da ändert auch der Code der
Crew nichts dran in simulationsversuchen
auf der Erde reichte einfach Düngung
auch gar nicht um den simulierten maßre
zu einem brauchbaren Boden zu machen und
auch die notwendigen Bodenorganismen
gibt es im Code nicht und schon gar
nicht im Maß regulit also spannend
leider unrealistisch aber noch nicht der
größte plottbrecher ein grundlegendes
Problem von Mark Watney ist also so
offensichtlich wie einfach auf dem marß
fehlt es an natürlichen Rohstoffen Dinge
die für uns selbstverständlich sind wie
Erde Mikroorganismen oder allein das
Wetter sind essentielle Bausteine des
Lebens fehlt eines davon bricht direkt
Chaos aus das zeigt mal wieder wie
genial unsere Erde ist und wenn ihr das
auch feiert dann könnte eine Uhr oder
auch Schmuck von Holzkern etwas für euch
sein Uhren von Holzkern bestehen aus
natürlichen Materialien primär natürlich
aus Holz daher auch der Name dieses
Modell ist aber beispielsweise auch
wasserdicht weshalb ich sie zum Duschen
gar nicht mehr ablegen muss mit dem
hochwertigen Quarzuhrwerk der Marke
saiko ist die dazu auch noch sehr
präzise und muss nicht täglich geladen
werden wie z.B eine SmartWatch wenn eine
aber nicht für euch ist dann hat
Holzkern auch noch ganz viele andere
schicke Accessoires im Angebot und egal
wofür ihr euch entscheidet die Produkte
von Holzkern werden alle in Klein Serien
per Hand gefertigt sind also immer stark
limitierte Auflagen und ihr bekommt
garantiert immer ein Unikat in der
Videobeschreibung findet ihr neben einem
Link zum 15% dr Watson Rabatt noch einen
Link zum Instagram Profil von Holzkern
für alle die interessiert sind lohnt es
sich vielleicht da Holzkern zu folgen
denn es könnte vielleicht eventuell sein
dass es sehr bald zeitlich begrenzte
aber preislich sehr interessante
Angebote dazu finden
gibt schauen wir uns watne nächstes
Problem an wie sende ich ein
Lebenszeichen zur NASA für die
Kommunikation will wne die Plattform
einer früheren Mission benutzen
Pathfinder Pathfinder und ihr Rover s
journa erkundeten
1997 für dreieinhalb Monate
ferngesteuert den Maß na ja ein ganz
kleines bisschen davon watne fährt mit
einem von zwei ziemlich robusten und
großen elektrischen Fahrzeugen zu der
Stelle hin und zwar tagelang immer
wieder muss er pausieren um das Fahrzeug
mit Sonnenenergie aufzuladen nun kostet
es wahnsinnig viel Geld und Ressourcen
gleich zwei große und schwere Rover zum
Maß zu schicken sind die Rover also
überhaupt realistisch ich hab selber
schon in so einem Teil drin gesessen
2018 sie brauchen ein Gewissen Raum man
muss da auch mal eine Nacht drin
schlafen können ist wie ein Camper
gleichzeitig ne und ja klar ich meine
solche Rover sind ausgelegt für
Expeditionen die einen vom habitat in
einem bestimmten aktionsradus rumführen
und
ja solche Rover die sind
klar sie müssen robust sein sie müssen
lange halten auch sie brauchen
Strahlenschutz okay gut und Watney hat
großes Glück während die modernste
Technologie seiner Station nach wenigen
Tagen auf dem marß zerstört wurde ist
perfinder nach 40 Jahren immer noch
funktionsfähig früher hat man halt noch
Wert auf gute Qualität gelegt
die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten von
pafinder sind aber begrenzt die NASA
holt deshalb die ehemaligen pafinder
Ingenieure aus dem Ruhestand sie sollen
helfen die Kommunikation zu verbessern
und dazu benutzen Sie eine Kopie von
pafinder als Modell das wird tatsächlich
auch so gemacht dass man wirklich
Modelle von von dem hat was man zum Mars
schickt und da an diesen Modellen dann
eben das ausprobiert was man auf dem MA
auch probieren möchte whatne kann dann
per Textnachrichten mit der NASA
kommunizieren immerhin so kann die NASA
ihm erklären wie er vom Maß wegkommen
kann und das ist ein wagalsiger
stand als sein Team zur Erde kommt
nutzen Sie in einem sogenannten
Slingshot Manöver die Gravitation der
Erde um gleich wieder Richtung Maß zu
beschleunigen wenn ihr Schiff die Hermes
am Mars ankommt muss sich Watney einfach
nur im richtigen Moment mit einer Rakete
in den Orbit schießen damit die Crew ihn
einfangen kann aber die Hermes kommt
wegen eines neuen Kurses höher und
schneller an als das Maß return modil
fliegen kann deshalb muss Watney
improvisieren er muss die Kapsel 5
Tonnen leichter machen viele
lebenswichtige Systeme und sogar die
Fenster und die Spitze der Rakete sollen
alle raus stattdessen soll eine
Abdeckplane über die Kapsel ziehen die
maßluft die ist ja so dünn also der der
Luftwiderstand die die bremsdrücke oder
der der Staudruck der da herrscht der
ist
vernachlässigbar ein ganz kleiner
kernwahrheit steckt also schon hinter
der Idee aber realistisch ist das leider
nicht watne macht also die Kapsel
leichter die Hermes kommt und er startet
aber leider reißt die Plane ab der
Luftwiderstand wird doch zu groß und
erreicht trotz allem nicht die
notwendige Höhe deshalb muss jetzt die
Hermes ihre Geschwindigkeit drosseln mit
einer selbstgebasselten Bombe sprengen
sie eine Luke und die schlagartig
ausströmende Luft bremst das Schiff ich
will nicht sagen das schlechteste Moment
im Film aber da da hat für mich weh
getan weil das sollte man echt nicht
machen und die Aktion hat nicht mal
gereicht der Abstand zwischen watne
Kapsel und der Hermes ist immer noch zu
groß deshalb geht die Kommandantin mit
einer man maneuvering unit auf
Außenmission um wne einzufangen und
natürlich ist ihre Sicherheitsleine zu
kurz kurz entschlossen schneidet Watney
seinen Handschuh auf um die ausströmende
Luft als Antrieb zu nutzen und wir
können sehr gut sehen wie einfach das zu
kontrollieren
ist das ist Wahnsinn aber auf der
anderen Seite ich habe ich habe also
auch gelernt manchmal ist 2 + 2 = 5 und
das muss man gelten lassen bei solchen
bei
solchen Missionen oder Herausforderung
also
das solche Visionen das das braucht man
auch damit
damit das ist das Salz in der Suppe ja
sage ich mal ob es hier natürlich stimmt
ja klar das müsste man jetzt nachrechnen
okay also riskant aber kann vielleicht
eventuell klappen manchmal muss man wohl
einfach hoch pokerern bis hierhin gab es
realistische und etwas weniger
realistische stellen aber alles war
bisher immer sehr gute Unterhaltung aber
jetzt gibt's noch einen ganz zentralen
Punkt der eigentlich den ganzen Plot des
Films zerstört und auf den wird im Film
sogar immer wieder
hingewiesen die Atmosphäre auf dem Mars
besteht zu rund 95% aus Kohlendioxid
außerdem beträgt der Luftdruck auf dem
Maß mit 6 mbar nur etwa
170 von dem auf der der Erde deshalb
muss man ja die Fluchtkapsel vielleicht
tatsächlich nur mit einer Plane abdecken
aber wenn man zu genau darüber nachdenkt
und das tun wir jetzt einfach mal reißt
genau das die gesamte Story ein auf dem
Mars gibt es häufig spektakuläre Stürme
ja dabei entstehen hohe
Windgeschwindigkeiten und der feine
maßregulit erzeugt Staubwolken bis zu 50
km Höhe genau so ein Sturm strandete
Watney am Anfang der Geschichte auf dem
Mars die Crew startet ja weil der Sturm
die Rakete umzukippen droht aber nichts
von dem wäre passiert denn zwar sehen
solche maßstürme beeindruckend aus aber
dadurch dass die Atmosphäre so extrem
dünn ist füt fühlt sich so ein Sturm von
weiß ich nicht 400 km pro Stunde fühlt
sich an wie so ein laues Lüftchen auf
der Erde das Schlimmste an so einem
Sturm ist deshalb dass Geräte wie
Solarpanels Rover und
Satellitenschüsseln mit Staub bedeckt
werden aber das war's dann auch schon
alles in allem hat niia also seine
Hausaufgaben gemacht es gibt zwar noch
einige Stellen wo ihm der Spannungsbogen
wichtiger war als der Realismus aber in
meinen Augen ist das auch vollkommen
okay am Ende des Tages wollen wir ja
unterhalten werden und kein paper lesen
wenn ein bisschen echte science im Film
steckt dann bin ich persönlich schon
sehr glücklich wenn ihr auch unterhalten
werden wollt aber auch gleichzeitig was
über Wissenschaft erfahren wollt vor
allem in Filmen dann ist Wissenschaftler
reagieren bestimmt was für euch das ist
ein monatlicher Livestream den wir für
ARTE auf Twitch machen wo wir immer mit
einer Wissenschaftlerin und einem
Wissenschaftler einen Science Fiction
Film gucken und den bewerten das ganze
geht doch mal viel mehr in die Tiefe ist
um einiges länger und macht immer sehr
sehr viel Spaß zuzugucken Link dazu ist
auch unten in der Videobeschreibung
ansonsten an euch vielen Dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric